hey everybody its Jesse and I hope
everyone had a good weekend and if
you're in the in the US I hope you had a
great long weekend I am I'm back to work
not quite as rested as I'd hoped to be
my youngest two children were very sick
all weekend so spent a lot of time
taking care of them so I'm not feeling
that that great myself so I'm gonna try
my best to to focus and be upbeat even
though I'm a little bit out of it so I
apologize in advance from just a little
bit a little bit off today if stuff
we're working on today should be a
little bit easier especially because we
have a pull request from Sebastian that
already did a lot of the work so the
first part of this is going to be
reviewing what was done in that pull
request so this would be kind of a nice
overview if you've never done form
validation on the client side with react
and that's what we will be working on
today so I think I put that in the
description and on my tweet but if in
case you didn't didn't read it actually
it's in the title as well but just to
kind of explain if you're not familiar
with it when you go to a form as I can
demonstrate so I type in something like
that and then immediately I'm told
that's not a valid phone number that's
what we're talking about just validating
the fields so we've already implemented
some things on the client side
to check to make sure we have the right
data mostly for the for the file upload
but we also want to give the user a me
get feedback right we if we just relied
what's I said when it when it comes to
forms right if you just rely on
server-side to do all your form
validation that's not a great user
experience it's secure in terms of not
letting in you know bad things into your
server that can mess it up but the user
has to wait you know they hit submit and
they have to wait for a response from
the server to let them know whether or
not you know that they put in the right
information so and if they hadn't then
most likely they're gonna have to redo
you know everything again what if they
don't get a response back immediately
say this for whatever reason the
response is delayed they could think
that they've submitted the form and
everything's alright and not realize
until later on that it's not alright so
you can see like that's not the best
with the client-side you get immediate
feedback like we just saw which is great
for a great user experience I
immediately know like oh wow that's not
a phone number you know definitely not a
valid phone number there so that's nice
but there's ways to bypass that and
still submit you know let's say this as
as a phone number so the best best thing
we could do is to have validation on the
server side and the client side so today
we're gonna check out how to do that on
the client side with react if you're
using something else like not let's not
react you know you just have a plain
HTML form using some vanilla JavaScript
or jQuery or something
then this isn't it's not gonna apply you
know exactly but there may still be some
things that are worthwhile to see that
that you could pick up from this so I'm
gonna say how'd everyone in the live
chat before you started hey everybody
that's cool and I guys see some I think
I see some new names in there so welcome
so Jacob said appreciate all these
videos thanks I appreciate you watching
and saying that okay so let's let's get
started with this I'm gonna set my timer
we're gonna go 25 minutes of kind of
coding while explaining and coding and
then I'll do five minutes and go to the
live chat catch up with any comments or
questions that you may have in case
you're interested
what's that react is the library not a
frame did I did I say that somebody
commented cast commented react as a
library not a framework yeah if I um I
don't really remember saying it so maybe
I said it was a framework but anyway
yeah I mean sorry if I if I said that in
the in the wrong way to be honest with
you I'm not even sure what the
difference between library and framework
would be like semantically so hello okay
now I see it wasn't me it was further up
in the live chat that you talked about
framework okay sorry about that I didn't
catch that immediately but anyway yeah
I'm going to tell you the truth here
framework and library thrown around like
interchangeably and I'm probably guilty
of that as well I don't really think
about it when I say that but I'm not
entirely sure of where that what the
definition is of each and where that
line is where something falls into a
framework or a library so if I use them
interchangeably I'm sorry I don't I
don't mean to be confusing about that
but I myself as some somewhat confused
about that definition but in any case
we're gonna learn how to do some stuff
with react regardless of what what
category it is so but I'll do my best to
try to remember
that react is a library let's see I
don't know why I've troubled with react
I don't really call jQuery a framework
ever I think I'm pretty sure I called a
library all the time so just have to get
that and in my head alright so let's go
ahead and start out oh I do want to say
for for anyone watching on Instagram
check out the free code camp YouTube
channel if you want to see the code for
this it's being live streamed right now
if you're watching later on though the
recording will be available and then the
code is also available on github you can
get the link to that in the in the
YouTube video this particular video is
titled
something it's client-side react form
validation so you can check that out if
you get a chance all right so let's
let's get to this so you can see already
how this works we have similar things
going on with email we also have some
some things going on with our file
upload so let's let's see how we
implement this first of all so let's go
to our package JSON file you see we're
using form Z in particular forms he
reacts but also forms a material UI
which is it's pretty awesome that they
have that that makes things a lot easier
I'm gonna say again I said at the
beginning but I want to say it again so
everybody knows that Sebastian did
pretty much pretty much all the work
actually Sebastian has done all the work
for this so far I don't think I've
changed anything for this yet we'll
probably add to it today but Sebastian
has done all this in a pull request so I
want to give him credit giving
for that and let's see so we want to
load these two and of course these are
available on github to check out the
documentation but basically the forms
EEGs is going to do check the validation
so we don't have to write all that
ourselves and then because we're using
forms of material UI it integrates well
with material UI which we're already
using and as you've already seen it fits
well we do have some weird things going
on here with spacing below here which we
can work on that later on it's not I
mean it doesn't break anything it just
looks a little bit odd there's a lot
more space than we really need there but
other than that it looks really nice
with with material UI okay so we'll just
start at the beginning of our service
request J s component and this is the
component that handles pretty much
everything on this page so we've brought
in
there we go let's try to figure out
where we brought informed you so we're
importing form Z and we're importing
form Z text and forms the check box so
this will come into play a little bit
later on but we have our file extensions
here so these are the types the file
types for a lot of the things that we do
want to allow I'm gonna have to double
check this list and make sure it is
everything but so far it looks from from
just looking over it it looks like this
is everything that we do when I accept
all right so let's let's scroll down to
where we're actually implementing some
of this so if we check out
here we go all right so we have some
extra things here that we didn't have
before
so our validations right in our
validation error but if I should do this
I guess I'll do it right now I was
thinking it might be easier to see
what's changed if we just go from the if
we go back to the commit where this was
added actually that might be yeah that
might be the best way to do it
yeah let's go back so for the part at
least where I just want to show what
we've done so far I think it will be
best if we just can see the difference
in github so I guess then go back to the
original pull request
okay so we've already checked out the
package.json I'm gonna have to make this
a little bit bigger I'm sure it's hard
to see well that's that's a lot bigger
okay
yeah yeah okay this is what we want to
look at so
okay here we go
so there's some other stuff that
happened in this pool request so that's
why I skipped over a lot because it's
not immediately related to form
validation okay and I actually did miss
this going through on our originally
when I went through so we've wrapped
everything in a form Z component so I'm
glad I did this because this is
obviously a key thing that's dismissed
so we've wrapped everything in a form Z
form component okay so the you know the
actual structure has changed a bit and
so on valid submit that a lot of this is
if you want more in-depth stuff you can
check out form Z on github but a lot of
it is worded in a way that it's really
self explanatory so if the valid submit
we just handle the form data alright
when it's when it's submitted which this
is you know we've already worked on that
in a previous previous stream if it's
invalid then we notify form error so
there you go so when we notify form
error we just are opening up a dialogue
so a modal is coming up and I guess I
could demonstrate this so let's try to
so this is obviously not right let's try
to submit okay so please fill out this
field
you can see that the tooltip comes up
please felt this field and actually I
think I had mistakenly said that a modal
comes up it's not it's not even old
actually this this does seem like
yeah that does seem like that would
throw up the same modal as if we
actually had like a form error come back
from the server but the thing is this
this probably won't fire if we have the
fields like this right because it's
going to come up with that tooltip first
so within our form Z component right we
have form Z text which is obviously for
a text field and so we have a lot of the
same things as we had for our original
material UI component so we are floating
label text right name value so mostly
the same stuff but we've made this field
required right so if we want to submit
I'll get rid of these so we don't get
errors from that but before we could
have just submitted this just like this
but now right it will not let us submit
which is nice because before on this the
live version of this which is basically
done with just jQuery to make something
required would have actually required a
bit more code than that but now to make
it required keep going over the wrong
screen literally all we have to do is
just put required rights so pretty easy
now and then for our validations we just
have the field type in there so we're
pulling in let me see if we're pulling
in the data we have it so we now have a
data file but we may not actually be
pulling it in yet let's
let me double-check
okay we are at work we're pulling in
that data and you're great so let me
show you that file then because I have
it up here anyway I did have it up to
make sure I stove it up there we go okay
so now we've we've removed the data a
lot of the data into this file and by we
I mean Sebastian but so you can see
right we have the name we can put
required true in here that's why when we
were pulling this in then I'll just show
you on this screen since since we're
here since we're pulling this in what
we're iterating over this data and you
know we're not directly obviously
putting in true or false we're pulling
it from here alright so if we wanted to
make it required we just changed the
data here in our data file and we
actually put in the error message as
well so that tooltip that comes up we
have control over what it says we also
have control over the type right so
we've said this is email this is alpha
right so we don't want any any numbers
or like weird characters in the name so
this is just going to be regular letters
right for our phone number we just want
numbers so is numeric and then for
Department we want to allow both letters
and numbers so we say alphanumeric right
so as I said earlier it's it's really
nice the way this is set up because
everything is pretty straightforward so
that's our our single line the multi
line set up it's pretty much the same
way so we go go form Z form Z text again
all right so it's the same one but we're
gonna say what are we gonna multi line
somewhere in here we got to say it's
multi line I can't see it right now
that's actually weird so I'm pretty sure
with the with the original material UI
components we had to put somewhere in
here that it was multi-line maybe I'm
just not seeing it right now obviously
it's working right we can see we can see
that this is actually using one maybe
it's not
hey let's fix this right now
so I did have these as multi-line but it
looks like it's not letting me make this
multi-line so let's check out form Z
which I think I have up on another
window so
there we go so if you can't tell already
I'm actually reviewing this live so as
we're going over this I'm reviewing I I
was working on something else today and
kind of saving this for for the stream
so I expected that I would find some
things that I wanted to change so here's
the first thing let me make sure this is
formed oh I'm looking at the wrong thing
I thought I had formzee up already but I
guess it didn't alright let's move this
over because that's not what we need
I think we have a link to whoops
conversation
Sebastian included a link to everything
there we go so we're gonna check out
formzee material UI
I guess we'll just check out regular
formally okay okay
yeah
that's weird actually I want to try this
obviously you could see as I was
scrolling through there wasn't anything
there that was describing what to do so
what I'm gonna do here is just check
actually it'll be faster just do like
this
let's just check out what it was before
for a multiple inputs multi-line okay so
we just had to pass a multi-line and
that was it so let's try to pass
multi-line and see if it works I think
it's worth it to try that out because if
it works it'll save us a lot of time and
trying to find out the answer
there we go all right awesome okay I'm
glad that works so basically if you want
if you want to use form Z text and make
it multi-line you just add multi lines
so just like the normal material UI
component okay great so now we have our
multi line components but it works the
same way in terms of validation right we
we could put our own custom error
message and then we can put our type for
all of these it's gonna be it's the oft
America afternoon the project budget
we've put numeric this we may we may
change this field I'm gonna leave it
like this for now but we may change this
field we're having some basically for
the budget we could put in some people
put in a budget code for their
department some people put in a dollar
amount but it's potentially people could
describe what their budget is because it
could be contingent upon other factors
so we may want to switch this to it's
alphanumeric but I'll need to check I
think I mentioned last week that so this
week I'm gonna make a server and I'm
gonna put this up and it's going to be
live and then other people in my
department can test it out at that point
I'll get some feedback on how we want to
change these form fields and this is one
of the ones that that may change
okay so great you can see majority of
these are just gonna be alphanumeric
that's probably what you want normally
when you have a multi-line input because
why would you want a multi-line input of
just all numbers right you would
normally wouldn't need that okay so
these are our all our text fields with
the validation like that's that's really
easy validation so I know I've I've
tried to do my own validation before
usually with jQuery it's so much harder
than this I really appreciate how this
is done so much so much easier I don't
think we have yeah we don't even going
on for the date picker which is fun for
now I'll have to check and see what how
you're how you can do date picker I'm
assuming that you can validate date
pickers with formulas we can check on
that in a minute once we finish going
through was here already normally if you
would just use the date picker as is
it's gonna format the date correctly but
potentially you know I guess someone
could try to enter in their date
disabled I know just in case somebody
has a way to try to enter in their date
manually we want it to be in the correct
format this is not going into a database
or anything so I'm not worried about you
know the exact format coming through but
it needs to be readable and makes sense
and the Dayton this may end up being a
required field as well okay so for our
file input
we have accept and then that's where
these file extensions extensions come in
but we want okay so what I need to test
out is the extensions so I need to try
to upload something that doesn't fit any
of those extensions and see what happens
all right let me check my time okay we
got about five minutes so let's test out
this file upload because what I was
getting before let's think
okay it's not letting me accept this
it's not letting me let me put in a file
let's see with what I'm thinking what
happened what I'm hoping will happen is
that it will also alert me so let me see
if I can there we go
so let's say I do that so me right away
you know it let me know that I couldn't
use that but let's say I switched all
files when I try to do something like
this I want to see ok nothing happens
yet let's see if it it's gonna make me
fill this out there's all this requires
ok let's see no I don't want my address
all right
I didn't realize that all these is
required is everything required right
now oops
alright let's just fill out everything
okay so it looks like nothing's
happening on that file input so let me
check out I want to make this a bit
smaller because it's hard for me to read
with it that big
hmm
maybe it just doesn't have this
let me scroll through quickly if it
doesn't have anything for this I guess
we'll just skip over for now
actually whoops there it is I'm looking
here's the API reference this is what
I'm looking for
okay validations
all right so I'm not seeing anything
about file input in here so for now
let's just just skip ahead all right and
that's my five minutes so let me go
let's set my um let's set my timer we'll
do a short break five minutes I'm gonna
go into the live chat which looks like
there's a lot of activity in the live
chat so I'm gonna try to get through
everything in five minutes then we'll go
back to it I think I think for now I'll
skip over that file upload and then I'll
show what's going on here with this
check box and then we can go through and
alter some things I definitely don't
want everything to be required right now
if we have time we can come back to the
upload files what I would like to happen
is that if someone tries to upload
something that's not supported it
immediately tells the user that it's not
supported all right okay see text editor
looks amazing current use brackets do
you recommend Adam as a better text
editor so the question is do you
recommend Adam as a better text editor
better than brackets I've never used
brackets so I can't make any comparison
between the two I like Adam have been
using Adam for years I've also tried
Visual Studio code I like it it seems
really fast I'm happy with Adam but I
think there's a lot of good alternatives
so I would be fine recommending Visual
Studio code as well the only reason I
don't use it right now more than I
already do is just because I have so
many packages already
set up with Adam and you know my syntax
highlighting you just get used to it a
certain way and I just haven't taken the
time to set up visual studio code in the
same way but you know if you're not
happy with your current editor then
Adams you know Adams a great thing to
switch to the only complaint I've heard
from Adam is some people say it slow I
haven't really had a problem with it
being slow for me I it probably also
depends on your machine you know and how
good your computer is I'm I'm on an iMac
right now that has you know pretty a
pretty decent amount I think I'm running
like 32 gigs of ram or something that's
a lot so I don't really have problems
with it but if you'd notice if you use
Adam and you notice that it's a bit
sluggish then I would recommend maybe
going with Visual Studio code because it
it does seem faster to me at least in
you know a little bit that I've used it
but there's a lot of other good editors
I've heard good things about sublime
people that use vim seem to really love
them I haven't taken the time to learn
that yet
one day I'd like to mess around with it
and see if I could learn it there's what
else people people who use Emacs really
love Emacs so I guess I can't
I've never even attempted to use Emacs
so I can't speak personally about it but
but I I feel comfortable saying you know
Adams worked well for me and I like it I
don't know if it's the best or not but
it's it serves its purpose well for me
okay so let's say there's some
discussion about the react license and
so I'm not
yeah I'm not necessarily I don't think
there's any questions in regard to that
let me double-check yes I don't think
they had any questions directly for me
but just in general there's been a lot
of controversy over the react license
from what I understand and this is also
reiterated in the live chat is that
there's something in the license about
giving up the right to sue Facebook if
you're using react or I think there's
also some other Facebook code that is
licensed in a similar way based like you
can't sue Facebook if you're using that
so I'm not sure about the details I'm
not I'm not a patent attorney I'm kind
of lawyer so I don't really know but it
seems to me like it's in most cases this
is just my take personally on it so you
know check it out for yourself but it
seems to me that in most cases you
wouldn't really need to worry about it
I'm not worried about it for for what
I'm using it for so I think it would
just depend on your use case your
company you know who you're working for
so but it's definitely worth I think
you'd begin to check it out understand
what's going on before you use react in
a larger project I think it's still fine
to use it you know certainly on you know
small side projects things like that it
at least from from what I have heard it
should still be fine for most people
alright I'm just scrolling through the
last a little bit here in the live chat
before we start up again there's some
mention of potentially using pre-act or
view j s as an alternative i think
someone mentioned angular as well
okay I'm gonna go I'm not gonna be able
to get through everything because
there's a lot of stuff in the live chat
right now I'll check it back after the
next 25 minute session it looks like
somebody asked about knowledge of react
in regard to this stream so yeah it
definitely it would help to understand
what's going on if you had some
knowledge and react but it just depends
on what we're working on so sometimes we
work on even though it's a react project
sometimes we work on parts of the
project that don't have that much to do
with react so you don't need to know
react to understand what's going on a
lot of it is just regular JavaScript
stuff or sometimes we're working on you
know the server which we're using node
for which is more JavaScript and so it
kind of just depends on what we're
working on today some of the stuff is I
would say probably most of the stuff
today is more unique to react but not
unintelligible to someone who hasn't
used react okay and let me I was gonna
write down where I where I'm leaving off
that but I can't seem to find a pen so
let me bring up my node I've been using
Google keep for notes lately so I'll
just write down the timestamp of where
I'm at in the live chat in keep since I
can't find a pen all right
oh cool a my said I said hey Mark how's
it going alright let's go back to this
I've already taken up more than my five
minutes of time okay and you have to
excuse me for a second I my first really
it's hurting today of a mouse getting
dry I need to stop and take a drink here
okay okay so the last thing that I want
to go over before we really start
getting into it and making some changes
is this checkbox here so we worked on
this earlier by earlier I mean maybe a
few weeks ago in a stream but we want
people to read the planning guide first
so you can see this is completely
disabled so I'm clicking this right now
nothing's working it's grayed out until
we check that now you can use that so I
kind of like how this is I may add I
think it'd be nice to make the cursor
change and maybe a tooltip
come up that says you know hey you got
it you got to read the Planning guide
something like that yeah I'd like maybe
to give some indication to the user if
they're confused as to why this isn't
working that they need to check this
first but other than that this is
working as as expected so not only is
this a required field but you know goes
even further that it completely disables
the submit button if you haven't checked
it so let's check out how that's done
we'll scroll down to the bottom here so
we have here we go so we've used the
formzee checkbox component instead of
the normal checkbox and obviously you
know we've added required we name but
we've also see and this may not be
related to form Z this may be something
that Sebastian did on his own I suspect
it is something like that and I don't
think he's in the lab chat so I don't
think you can verify that but
I'm pretty sure this is something he did
on his own but it's it's a nice feature
so we'll go over it because it is you
know we're validating that this is
checked so let's look enable submit so
basically on change we're enabling
submit so let's go up and check out that
function enable submit okay so if it's
checked we're gonna set the state the
can submit state to true if we're
unchecking it we want to set it to false
all right so pretty simple and we could
see by default it's false and then let's
check our submit button
here we go okay so we have this disabled
property and we're just checking for if
we can submit and you know we want to do
the opposite right so if if it's can
submit is true we want this to be
enabled right so that's why we're doing
the opposite so if can submit is true
then this value is going to be false and
if it's not true right so if it's if
it's unchecked and it's not true then
it's going to end up registering as true
so disable true right so pretty
straightforward I really like how
Sebastian did that it's just it's so
simple I mean it it gets the job done
it's great so that's basically all we
have going on right now for form
validation so what I want to do now is I
know there are certain things that are
not going to be required see yeah let's
let's just put in false for some of
these and then that way if we need to go
and test the form later on it'll be a
lot easier primary target audience I'm
gonna say false for a lot of these now
[Music]
I'm gonna say false now but that that's
likely to change my goal now that I look
at these I kind of don't really like how
they're a lot of how they're worded but
I'm not gonna change anything right now
because initially when I did this
project two years ago I think yeah I
think two years ago I started this
project not this particular react
project but the the version of this
that's live right now that was done with
jQuery it's basically kind of it's
common like a single page application
but just on the jQuery to handle all the
different views there was a lot of
debate as to what these form fields
would be and how they would be worded so
I'm not gonna just change anything on my
own without checking to it was a big
deal that's what everything what it all
said I'm gonna leave the description as
true we need something to go by so when
it need the description the Department
I'm gonna leave it as false right now
just for the sake of testing the form
that will probably end up being true
phone email I'm gonna go with funding
Falls but I definitely want an email and
if we make the email required then this
would be better so on the server side
we're sending an email and I want to
send an email to the user so I don't
really even want to have to worry about
there not being an email obviously I'm
gonna I'm gonna have some type of
default if we don't get an email because
someone could circumvent the client-side
validation but I'd like there to the
user to put in an email so that we could
send them an e-mail verification and get
a hold of them later
name required let's um let's format this
in the same way as the other ones there
we go okay name sure and we want the
name to be required as well let's get
onions check out these checkboxes okay
great so I'm gonna say that so here's
what I'd like to work on now let's see
if there's a way and we may have to do
this on our own
and not use forms a which is fine but
it's assuming that that form Z does not
have a way to do this on file uploads
what we need to do then is unchanged
since probably since we already have we
already have a non change handler let's
just do this in our own change so when
we with the handle file path we're gonna
need to check the file type against
these extensions and then display
something to the user if they're if
they've tried to upload something that's
not on the allowed list all right so
ok let's check out this handle filepath
so that
so she'd be able to get
let's
let's see if we can get
I'm doing this the wrong way let's see
files the
so with this I think we can go
I want to see if we can get the type
right from here so what we're doing here
then is as we can see here we have this
files object that we get back from our
our upload field and we can get the name
of the file off of it I think we can get
the type just by doing tight but I want
to double check my console logging I
actually have two different ideas right
now since we have all those types I want
to use those so if we can get the type
and it matches up with the with the
format of the types that we already have
saved here then that would be great
otherwise I'm gonna grab the name and
then get the file extension from the end
of the name and then we'll go to our
server j/s and we have a list of allowed
extensions there we can copy that over
and use that either way will work so
probably won't matter what what we do
there it's gonna work
file is not defined well not defined
oops file snaps area
okay let's check out there's our
consoles let's try to upload some stuff
there we go okay so we are getting the
file type I'm interested to see what the
type is what type that says when I do
this there's not xxe okay great
so we are getting what we want from here
so we will be able to work with what we
already have let's see I want to see
what format we have this in okay this is
just a string all right that's fine we
can work with this drink all right so
let me let me take a step back and just
explain what's going on here
especially if there's someone who's kind
of a beginner or doesn't really
understand some of the ex6 stuff or file
upload stuff so there's a lot of
different things going on here that you
may not have been exposed to so we're
going handle file path we're using arrow
functions so this is just a function and
as a parameter we're passing in the
event they were using the arrow function
the main advantage to this other than
being concise is that it binds this and
in a way in react that we want this to
be bound although I don't even think
yeah we are sorry you see here we're
using this set state if we use a regular
function and try to call this set state
I don't think it would work
yeah we would have to bind this
somewhere else if we wanted to use the
regular function so in particular we'd
have to bind it in a constructor
why not I'm not going to go into that
right now we've talked about that in
previous streams so anyway I think an
arrow function here is the best way to
go to accomplish what we want to do in
as few lines as possible
but if you're not familiar it's just a
shorter way of writing a function so for
our purposes we really just need to know
what's going on here right now so we're
getting so we're setting this constant
as files and any time you see Const or
let think variable okay there's there's
some things going on with scope and
mutability whether you want to use costs
or let but it's just another way to make
a variable so we have this target dot
files right so our event target that
we've passed in the event all right and
we're just grabbing the files from that
okay so now we have an array of files
and I might be easier if I console.log
what's going on here let's do that let
me put in some console logs I think
it'll be I usually get things a lot
easier if I can see it so let's type
let's put in console let's just put in
an event for nought and I think we
should be able to see everything we need
to from that so let's try to upload
multiple files here ok great so we have
ok so here's our event right and we can
access target
let's see if we can find it I was gonna
be getting in here so I've been targeted
files
I'm not gonna be able to get this hmm
I might have to go down another one
let's go let's get event.target
okay so here we go our event target is
simply our input right so we're
selecting our input and then we're
getting our our files off of that so one
more time I'm going to change the files
there we go so now you can see what
we're getting we have an object and
we're getting our files and then we have
some values from there all right so we
have our name and we have our type right
our file size so we have a lot of useful
values in here especially useful for a
validation so that's what we're getting
right and that's what we're we're doing
here I guess just to show you the
difference of what's going on here
let's throw this
there we go this should hopefully be the
last time we need a console.log for
demonstration purposes alright so you
see before we had an array now we have
or before we had an object now we have
an array of objects right so that's just
for the purposes of being able to
iterate over it using map over we're
using here alright so that's all we did
there so now we're already grabbing the
file names and we're using that to
display so we're not using the default
upload field that's just the default
HTML field because it's not pretty so
since we're using something different
these are two different inputs this is a
multi-line input and we're actually
grabbing the file names from our upload
input and then putting them into this
field here that's why we need to do that
but it's nice that we're already doing
that because a lot of the stuff we need
for validation is already written out so
now what we're gonna do is we're gonna
grab that type which we've been console
logging already and let's get rid of
this we don't need it anymore so now
what we need to do is check every for
every file we need to check the type and
make sure that that type is included in
our list of allowed file types if it is
then we're not gonna do anything it's
just gonna go through as normal if it's
not then we want to show the user some
feedback so for now let's just get it
get the check working then we'll decide
how exactly we want to show the feedback
to the user
I just saw Praveen in the live chat just
as is it react yes yes it is react Jaso
let's go with and I'm gonna I'm gonna
have to check the syntax on this because
I always get it wrong
[Music]
actually I could just check in server
dodge is because I've used it so here we
go
all right match use match you don't
really need match like this
yeah we can use this so
yeah let's use this I was just checking
because I can never remember the order
so you can see the difference between
with match we put in first like the name
of the file and then we type in like
what we want to match it against with
test its opposite first we have our list
of what we want to match it against and
then we have our our individual value so
I just wanted to double check head so
that's what we're gonna do so we want to
do is actually let's let's console log
this console of this for now so we can
see if it's working so for this we want
to do our then I don't remember what the
name is there we go our file extensions
list
actually no this isn't how we want to do
actually we do want to do this a little
bit different from we are doing so I
forgot it again sorry file extensions
and then
alright let's see what it does I think
I'm confusing myself Asst which one goes
where but let's just check it out for
now whoa
hmm
yeah I think I put that back
okay the shad is done
now again hmm I don't something wrong
let's try it with match and I may have
to switch it around
okay
okay this will work I don't know what I
was doing wrong with tests but this is
fine this or two so you can see we're
getting values all right so in this case
we're getting an array if it matches if
it doesn't match for getting null so an
easy way to check this it's just so
we'll go you see where my if it is let's
see dot length is greater than zero then
actually let's just return this I was
just math linker is here this should be
sufficient
oops
oops
Cantrell active no okay
all right so they are getting true there
let's just change it then and say
all right this should give us what we
want
books
okay there we go that's what you want so
we tried to upload two pings and then
one xcf file so we got two trues because
things are on the list and then false
because xcf is not on list so that's the
behavior that we want let me check my
timer did that go off or did I just
forget to set it let me see what time it
is no that definitely went off okay
let's take a short break and sorry about
that I just did not hear that at all all
right I'm gonna go back to the live chat
right now and try to catch up
now I'm gonna scroll back up to where I
left off
see
okay we were when I left off that we
were talking a little bit about code
editors and I was saying that I've heard
that Adam is a little bit slow but it
runs fine on my machine
and Blake said Adam is pretty sluggish
on his machine
shroo John s which coding software are
you using sir if you're talking about my
code editor it's Adam if like in general
we're for this project we're using react
ok kerlick says I just tried Adam code
editor and in my opinion it is terrible
comparing with brackets okay so yeah
I've never used brackets before so like
I said I can't do a comparison but but
that's good to know
well like I said I'm not I'm not gonna
switch to anything else right now until
I you know if I get some time it let's
say I'm in between projects or something
and I have time to really try to setup a
different editor the way I like then
I'll think about switching but for now
since Adams working for me
then I'm just I'm gonna stick with it
alright matt said what are you what are
you doing with the image uploads
planning on displaying them elsewhere
accident no I didn't have any plans on
displaying the image uploads anywhere it
would be cool it would be a cool feature
and this will just go on like the nice
to have list of if we have time I'll put
it in there but it might not it might
not be a bad idea to display thumbnails
of the images when they're uploaded that
would be kind of nice to do but for now
the only kind of feedback the only thing
we're doing with the images for now are
they're just going to be stored on the
server and they're going to be sent to
the project management system that we
use
okay and I've actually got through I've
got through to the bottom of the live
chat so and I still have one minute left
okay so we'll probably do I'll probably
just do one more Pomodoro session we'll
see how much we can get done with this
file uploader and hopefully we can get
it finished you know or at least to a
point we're kind of displaying something
I mean right now it basically works
we're getting the result we want we just
need to do something visually now but
like I said we'll do one more session
and then I'll answer any questions that
any of you have in the in a live chat
there we go so let's start up our
session I think what I what I'd like to
do I'd love it if we had the same style
of let's see so not that one let me see
so this I think something like this
would be great to have for the file
upload or at the very least something
like this would work as well so it would
it would turn this line red and then
underneath it would say that it's not a
valid file extension
actually
all right so I guess here's what I was
just thinking I wonder if I could just
use the form Z validation on this
because this is just a multi-line input
and somehow give it a white list of file
extensions to check then I mean we
already have it working for the file
pose but then we wouldn't even really
have to have to check here the only I
mean potentially you could probably get
around this but for for the normal users
not trying to get around it
you know that's really what I'm worried
about here is giving them useful
feedback immediately I think it would
work and it might be easier to implement
so let's check it out we'll just we'll
just try something here
there we go here's a file upload ok so
right now this is just the text field
and it's not the form Z field
then you check out
let's check this out
there we go this is what I'm looking for
we could do a custom validation
okay so it looks like we can use this we
can use this function within validations
and do whatever we want to validate that
that's it this is exactly what we'll
need okay
I'm not I'm not really sure either
current values in the form
oh here we go that may be this is
business what one aid I've been through
some forest community
I think this might be what we need
to
okay
all right let's try this
[Music]
so I'm not
I'm not a hundred percent sure but I
think that this would be the best thing
for us to use so let's try it out on our
multi-line
here we got validations and then let's
get it
Haitians error
let's just try this just to see if we
get the air which we should
now we're not knocking the air
oh I didn't switch it to form Z
component okay so it just needs to be
form Z text all right I probably need
but see if it works mmm not working what
am I doing wrong here Oh name is mark
this required okay so we need a name
let's see if that
okay does not have the validation rule
is in
that's odd we get that from
now let's see what this is
mm maybe we want to try
alright let's just let's try regular
expression then alright so let's go to
our server Jess and let's see she I
don't really want to I want to match it
today's just a values truthful let's try
this
oops
okay
nobody should imagine
oops
all right cool let's see if we can get
it to not be an error all right
you know what though this isn't gonna
work I guess we could do this
I wish we could do this and make it work
yeah
yeah that's not gonna be the answer okay
so let me explain I guess I haven't
really been explaining what I was doing
too much sorry about that so what I had
done successfully was useless regular
expression to check that the that the
end of the string of filenames that we
have here contains one of these
extensions which is great that works but
logically that's not really what we want
to do because like you can see here as
long as I put a file name at the end
that does contain this you know a valid
extension I can put whatever I want here
so that's not gonna work so that's not
what we wanted so you may have to go
back to
yeah we may have to go back to what we
were originally working on so what I
wanted yeah actually what I want to
check to make sure see if it works is
could I just put in true or false
if I were to use this and then let's see
if we can return
return false let's see if we can get it
to return the air okay so that returns
false automatically
okay returns true all right so as long
as we return that from that function let
me see if I can just return something
just return false I can't just do that
okay
all right so let's just go back to this
so now we should be able to just grab
the our value from what we were doing up
here okay so when we were doing the
handle filepath
we should be able to
let's see if this works
let's add let's add something to state
I was valid
now you know what we have a loop here
let me see
what we may need to do
how's that all right sir mapping over
this
all right so here's what I'm gonna try
to do as this gets looped through if any
of the files in here don't match so if
it returns false then we're gonna change
it and so we're gonna save a value in
state and we're gonna either basically
if any of them are false then that value
in state is gonna be false
okay and initially yeah so initially
this is going to be set to true because
we don't want to show an error right off
the bat so true and then we're also
going to we're also going to set it
let's set it to true
this states
all right I want to set this to true
right off the bat because if the user
puts files in there it's gonna get set
to false but then if they do it again I
wanted to set back to true and then if
it checks everything it's going to keep
it at true and then within within this
I don't want to lock on soullow that
anymore what I want to do is so if true
I guess now we want to do this is so
good
[Music]
all we want to do is take
- beautiful right
all right I see Lily have tears yet
can I not do that when I said state you
see all right so I'm getting an error
now I'm trying to do formed up file
valid true
but I'm getting an error so I guess I'm
not I guess I can't do it like that
all right so I guess I can't do nested
stuff like
so let's go with
should say
okay
and
let's see that at least get rid of the
airs
ready
I think that I messed something up
inadvertently with my syntax let's see
so excuse
shouldn't have to put this let's see
yeah why is it this
thank you
okay I'm pretty sure my timer went off
yeah it did go off I hate to end on this
note syntax error but yeah I'm not sure
would I not sure what I did let me
I'm just gonna take a minute and see if
I can fix this if not probably just end
the stream and do some more
troubleshooting okay all right let's see
all right let's see if I can then try
this
all right see if we get that same area
no okay all right that's better it's
just I guess it didn't like that I was
trying to do that short circuit okay all
right I guess I'm gonna go for a few
more minutes you can get this working
since I figured that out I don't think
this is the best way to do it at least
it seems like it's a lot more than
should be needed but since I couldn't I
couldn't set state the way that I
originally tried to set state and I
actually can't believe that I never had
a need to do that before because I don't
remember running into that problem
before so I'm gonna try to do it this
way which is basically the way we're
doing it down here already so we know it
works
[Music]
all right so I just want to see what
what's going on with a state when we do
this now just to test that what we're
doing so far so we're gonna check in dev
tools react and should be able to their
yeah state form file Vela true okay
let's try to put in something it's not
true
all right great so we see file valid
went to false now let's cancel it good
and I went to true awesome okay so that
is acting how we want it so now we have
in state this value that goes true or
false depending on whether or not the
file let's put in is valid great and
that's checked against the the types
that we have here okay so the next the
next step then is to return
whoops passed it up there we go we need
to return in here in this function let's
go return
this is another place where I think
there's got to be a better way to do
this but let's see I'm not even sure if
I'll be able to get the value of this
here all right let's see what happens
I
good
okay
hmm
let's check out forms these I'm thinking
there's got to be a way to just set
instead of having to use this
dysfunction there's got to be a way that
I can just set true/false on the
validation I always I hate to just read
documentation on the stream but we're so
close to getting this so lol OS is it's
almost two hours can we end please
because yes that's give the bathroom if
you got to go to the bathroom and then
come back that's cool if you miss what
happens you could always check the
replays
do I need to include bathroom breaks
into the streams if they get long all
right let me check quickly here if there
is some way to set this
see
now that's not what I was looking for
there's a ballot ATSC
well
I don't think
I think I'm seeing anything validation
okay maybe we can add we can add a rule
let's see
okay
maybe this creates add validation rule
is the way to go for us
oh this doesn't really seem different
than what we're already doing
it's just extracting it out so maybe we
just need to figure out I don't even
really need this value value don't need
this maybe the problem is trying to get
this in here what if
I wonder if I couldn't make this an
arrow function
this work
we'll see I'm really not confident that
this will work but the only thing I can
think of is - why it's telling me that
let's see what Canada syntax is that you
know
whoa that actually did not get me there
maybe it'll work alright so let's try to
upload something that should give us an
error see what happens
nice Oh
let's cancel it out what's oh man it
works
let's try to try it with multiple files
I don't think we tried that yet
great yes without again oh yes all right
okay
so although I wasn't really confident in
what I was doing it worked so that that
was the case is that originally how this
was written basically we just copy and
pasted from from the docs there so
that's not what exactly what we needed
we needed to be able to have this be
what what we wanted it to be so we had
to use that error function when we did
that it worked so great so half court so
basically we have our validation now
immediately for the file upload great
probably would be cool to have a message
I'm thinking like to make this better it
might be cool to have the message
actually say what file is the file you
can't upload but for now it works I mean
this is entirely functional and does the
job as is but it can definitely be made
better well I'm happy I got that working
because us starting to think I would not
get that working before the end of the
stream
alright so streaming a little bit longer
than I that I thought okay so John B
just paste it in here a possible error
so the error file type xcf not supported
yeah that's definitely that's that's
like what that's exactly what I was
thinking so yeah I think that's possible
I'm not gonna try to do it right now
since streams already been two hours and
to be honest with you I'm just I'm
really exhausted I'm I guess at the
beginning I'm not really feeling well
and this these dreams take a lot out of
me cuz I try to at least seem like more
energetic even if I don't feel energetic
and that that effort alone takes a lot
of energy so alright so what I'm gonna
do now is I'm gonna scroll up a bit and
try to see if there are any questions
that I missed fire Scott says thanks for
the stream you're welcome Thanks thanks
for watching and being involved in the
live chat so yet if you are just here
for the code then and you got to go
totally understand thank you so much for
watching and I should be back tomorrow
unless I feel even worse than today and
then I might take a day off but
otherwise if you have any questions
please put that in the live chat now I
don't think there's a ton of questions
in the chat so it'll probably only take
me a few minutes to get through and when
I get through everything then we'll in
the stream feel free to ask whatever you
want if you're if you're new don't be
afraid to ask something you know really
any questions even if it seems really
basic is totally fine with me try to be
really beginner friendly in here okay
I was just I was reading some comments
about the person had hitted the bathroom
so that's why had a little laugh there I
don't think I'm gonna repeat him more
yeah okay John B I just saw your comment
about the right-hand braces way on the
right thanks for that I didn't notice it
at the time but that was definitely one
of the errors that I got there so thanks
for noticing that that was a good catch
I didn't even notice it at first fire
Scott says hey you could just move your
logic with file valid inside this custom
validator so you get rid of external
file valid and your component will be
compact okay I could check that out
I'm not a hundred percent sure what that
would look like right now I'd have to
check with the code but thank you for
the suggestion I'm definitely sure this
could probably be refactored to be
better usually that's how it is when I
cut things on the stream I'm trying to
go quickly so I don't usually even make
an attempt at refactoring anything so
actually that's a good disclaimer so
just so you know especially if it's
starting out the code that comes out
during the stream is probably not like
ideal all the time but usually it ends
up getting better as we go on so either
somebody submits a pull request and
refactor it or if I get a chance I
refactor it later on so the finished
product is usually what you'd want to go
with but I often I think the stream
would be really really long it's already
pretty long but it would be really long
if I tried to go back and refactor
everything so just kind of be aware that
there's probably a better way to do a
lot of the stuff that I do during the
stream
Oh Rory said something's going on with
free code camp can't get online okay I'm
not sure I haven't tried to get on a
free code camp yet today and I don't
have anything to do with the free code
camp website or the servers so I'm sorry
I can't I can't give you an update on
what's going on right now I would check
check the free code camp Twitter because
they're usually pretty good about
putting out some sort of message on
Twitter as to whether if something's
happening and when you can expect to get
back on so I would check there hopefully
there's some type of update on their
Twitter
I breathe
bright it looks like Brian I'm not sure
to pronounce that so it looks like Brian
O'Driscoll says hi guys joining the
party a bit late but I can catch up on
videos repeats Jessie you're on a roll
today Thanks
yeah it was it was a struggle for a
little bit but we got it working so
thanks a couple feels saying I thanks
thanks to the shame you're welcome thank
you so much for being and watching
Umberto's says I definitely understand
using so much energy during the stream I
finished recording my first official
video last night 1.5 hours of recording
and found that the screen capture didn't
oh no this is Ola I recorded a silent
version of the work I did that thinking
I'm gonna do a voiceover okay well
that's cool man that that stinks when
you record stuff in a doesn't work I am
a few weeks ago I was trying to record a
tutorial video for a client and it was
really late and I was like yes I'm
finally gonna get this done it's the
last thing I have to do for this client
and then I checked and I had my settings
way off and the video quality was just
so terrible you couldn't even read
anything and I still haven't recorded it
I was just like so let down by that eyes
and I haven't really had time to get
back to it alright so it looks like one
more question so Alexander asks what's
the purpose of the use folder so it's
probably hard to see cuz it's so small
over here but in my project I have
things separated out so I have a Styles
folder a components folder and I have
this views folder the purpose of the
views folder is basically that each
component in the views folder acts like
a page in the in the actual
so you can see the names of each of the
views components corresponds to the name
of a page so this is the service request
components we have a home component I
think we have a home component a logo is
component so so that's what the the
views that used to so each component of
the use filter is a different a
different view so hopefully that makes
sense you certainly don't have to
organize it like that I just I just do
and I was kind of used to it from when I
use next j/s each you know they did
their routing based on the components so
I guess I kind of carried that over from
the last project I did using next of
having a component for each each for you
separate it out you know okay
all right well it's a white knife says
hi hey how's it going thanks for
watching
okay awesome uh-huh I got the name right
from earlier well I got it right the
first time so it's Bree and then I think
that we're saying all right
I'm definitely gonna I'm gonna end
things now I'm getting really tired so
thank you so much for watching I'll be
like I said I'll be back hopefully I'm
feeling better tomorrow and I'll be back
I'll be back into work and I could do
hopefully be a little bit more with it
during the stream but took a while in
the end we did get it get working what
we wanted to get working so we do have
form validation on on everything we need
to on our form including the the upload
the file uploader so so it's looking
pretty we're pretty close to having to
having this finished up at least
finished up enough to get some feedback
on and make some changes before we
actually launch this thing so I just got
two more questions let me do this real
quick since I got two more questions
here so zachary says hey could you make
a discord jst toriel series I don't
really know anything about it so if I
learn about it then I could definitely
do to Touro serious I guess but right
now I don't I don't know enough to be
comfortable to learn the tutorial and
rich-rich bob bob says sorry I'm getting
that wrong I'm pretty sure I get that
name wrong but says why is Ubuntu better
than Windows I don't I don't really I
don't really think I'm I can give you a
great answer for that there's so many
factors that go into choosing an
operating system
if you're thinking about it for an OS
for like a desktop OS potentially it
could be for servers as well they
windows server but right off the bat
Ubuntu is free so that's one reason that
I would think it's better but it totally
depends on what you're trying to use
them for as to whether or not one would
be better the other so anyway sorry I
couldn't give you a better answer for
that but I think that would be a better
question to kind of debate and get some
more feedback on but right now we can't
have the debate so maybe ask that
question again towards the beginning of
the stream and I'm sure you'll get a lot
of answers from everybody in the live
chat all right so this time for real I'm
going to end the screen even if I get
more questions I'm going to end it thank
you so much for watching and have a
great day